paul sanchez
tu te souviens pas le sanchez
c'est peut être la fin d'une cavale de
10 ans paul sanchez est activement
recherché depuis le meurtre sauvage de
sa femme et de ses quatre enfants il ya
dix ans sauf à 76,2 employés des serres
de la caricature vue ce matin
sanchez c'est du vent rien tu la trappe
ça me change je comprends pas
la fois où il avait communiqué la ya dix
ans c'était pour dire qu'il n'était pas
coupable
ça me dégoûte je peux les soirées
et là ce que vraiment bizarre c'est
qu'ils parlent au creusot vous êtes
complètement à côté
vous faites juste manipuler
je ne sais pas tué
jaz libéré la perte l'arrivée
vous tirez une la soif du sang il est en
crise
c'est malin c'est mon record c'est un
pervers
tu manipules nous ouvrons ce qui les
porte
ce n'était pas la vérité j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps à comprendre qu'il
était
je suis sanchez mais tous anglaise
comment danser marion venir là
[Musique]